mais on débat sur france 24 consacré à
la politique française au surlendemain
de la nomination d'elizabeth bornes
première ministre la chef de
gouvernement n'a toujours pas de
gouvernement
il devrait être formé dans les prochains
jours les défis à relever sont nombreux
vous le savez celui des élections
législatives mais aussi des dossiers à
traiter d'urgence comme celui du pouvoir
d'achat et réformes à mener comme celle
des retraites la priorité accordée à
l'écologie alors que l'onu tire une
nouvelle fois la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le changement climatique qui reste le
plus grand défi de l'humanité selon
l'organisation alors en attendant le
nouveau gouvernement quel dossier chaud
pour la première ministre elisabeth
board on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés catherine
tricot bon sens avancera directrice de
la revue regards bienvenue dans le débat
en face de vous janick halimi bonsoir
rédactrice en chef adjointe du service
politique au parisien aujourd'hui en
france bienvenue à vous également nous
avons également avec nous benjamin morel
bonsoir politologue maître de
conférences en droit public à paris 2 et
puis alain clerc ruelle bonsoir
fondatrice de cole paul un compte
instagram ce qui a d'ailleurs suivi
l'élection présidentielle vous êtes
consultante en communication politique
et publique on attend toujours donc ce
gouvernement on pensait que ça serait
hier puis aujourd'hui eh bien ce sera
peut être demain ou encore après-demain
janyk halimi est ce que c'est
particulièrement long alors qu'on ne
connaît encore ni le jour ni l'heure
d'ailleurs de la constitution de ce
gouvernement écoutez je crois que c'est
pas l'expérience la plus longue il y en
a eu des plus court certes mais il n'y a
pas de singularité particulière et de
d'exceptionnalité qui pourrait
apparaître comme scandaleuses ou
inquiétantes vous avez toujours
l'impression vous qui êtes journaliste
politique qu'on attend qu'on attend ça
c'est vrai à ce à quoi nous a habitués
emmanuel macron c'est nous donner des
dates des jours des horaires et puis de
ne pas les tenir ça c'est vrai que lors
d'un précédent remaniement du temps
d'edouard philippe je me souviens qu'il
y en avait eu au moins un on nous a fait
attendre au moins 72 heures mais par
rapport à un horaire données indiquées
par emmanuel macron ou ses proches donc
là s'est posé dans le flou on est dans
le flou mais il faut savoir que
constitutionnellement parlant il n'y a
pas d'obligation 1 pour soi pour le
premier ministre a pour président de la
république d'accélérer le processus il
n'y a aucune aucune contrainte juridique
et ils sont à peu près libre de leur
agenda benjamin morel oui pas
d'obligation dans la constitution du
tout on vrai près de délai ça pourrait
durer une vacance comme ça du pouvoir
pendant un certain temps alors ça peut
durer un certain temps mais évidemment
personne n'a intérêt à ce que ça dure
non plus trop trop longtemps d'abord
parce que vous avez un phénomène de
latence qui risque bien de marquer
l'opinion et ensuite parce que vous avez
des administrations qui du coup est bien
ne sont pas tout à fait téléguidé
lorsque nous vous n'avez pas de ministre
donc il faut malgré tout que ce soit
relativement court après il ya deux
impératifs qui font que ça dure le
premier impératif c'est que bien vous
avez un mercato qui est évidemment assez
complexe il faut donner des gages
géographique politique et c est le
deuxième élément c'est que depuis les
dernières lois de moralisation vous avez
là acheter bp est donc dès le moment où
vous examinez un profil il faut que la
haute autorité sur la transparence de la
vie publique à ce que vous allez vous
dire je le dis pour été spect
téléspectateurs pardon anne-claire euros
elle justement emmanuel macron ils
restent maîtres des horloges c'est aussi
une question de communication c'est ce
que j'allais dire on l'a beaucoup
attendu quand même durant cette campagne
on l'a attendu avant qu'il rentre en
scène et qu'il est qu'ils se mettent
justement à contrer c'est ses
adversaires qui n'attendait que lui en
fait pour essayer de se positionner il y
rentrer en scène surtout à l'issue du du
du premier tour évidemment et là on me
voit beaucoup plus évidemment être au
premier rang parce qu'il sent qu'il ya
quand même en danger avec notamment la
vitesse qui arrive et on va sans doute
parler justement l'année passée
catherine tricot c'est des profils des
mises sont revus donc un par la haute
autorité sur la transparence de la vie
publique mais on sent une certaine
impatience à gauche comme à droite
d'ailleurs qui critiquent déjà
évidemment ils les abattent bornes oui
ça y est ils ont des griefs à lui faire
et je trouvais assez
intéressant de noter que dans la
circonscription où elles se présentent
dans le calvados et bien il ya une
petite ligne qui a fermé grâce à ses
réformes c'est à dire que comme l a
conduit la libéralisation du dut
du réseau ferré une des lignes qui
desservaient sa circonscription a fermé
donc c'est pas un très bon indicateur ni
pour le plan de la cohésion du
territoire pour soutenir les gens qui se
sentent délaissés ni pour l'écologie
donc donc là je rejoignais c'est des
critiques de gauche essentiellement oui
c'est dire ce que voilà c'est ça que je
voulais dire c'est que en fait bornes
c'est ma khroubis bas ou wii scanlan à
l'avant est arrivé largement en tête
lors de la présidentielle dans cette
circonstance lui tout à fait tout à fait
et je pense qu'elle n'est pas menacée
mais je trouve que c'est quand même
savoureux de voir que dans sa
circonscription les effets de sa
politique des réformes qu'elle a
conduite se traduisent pas la fermeture
d'une vie d'une petite ligne ouais elle
va devoir se battre tout de même dans
cette circonscription elle va devoir se
battre d'abord à lui à égaler elle va
aller sur le terrain elle va faire
campagne puisque sans icn on parle de
d'émulation week end et puis elle va
certainement faire aussi dans toute la
france en tant que patronne de la
majorité chef de la majorité parce que
elle tient bien à marquer ce rôle là qui
n'est pas évident pour elle et c'est
pourquoi aussi la deuxième raison pour
laquelle il va falloir qu'elle se bat
c'est que ce n'est pas une et lui ça n'a
jamais été une élue donc de toutes
façons il faut qu'elle se bat maintenant
au regard
comparaison n'est pas raison surtout pas
dans ces élections mais tout de même
s'il ya un marqueur ou en tout cas un
thermomètre ça a été la présidentielle
comme la dernière qui est le dernier
scrutin et comme je le disais je n'ai
plus vraiment le chiffre en tête mais
emmanuel macron il avait en bray et de
l'arrivée bien en tête et face à lui
face à elle pardonnez moi il a est là
bas dit moi un candidat de la nuque qui
est un jeune un jeune homme de 22 ans et
les filles donc de ce point de vue là en
terme de retranscription nationale d'un
débat qui pourrait se passer à
l'assemblée nationale où ailleurs entre
la macro ni et la gauche et la france 1
soumises notamment
c'est intéressant dont est là elle va
falloir qu'elles se battent parce que
même si médiatiquement elle aura
évidemment une sorte de dynamique elle
et elle a déjà un passif comme vous le
disiez il a déjà un passif madame madame
bornes tout à fait mon fan est nommé
premier ministre à vous dire que c'est
un petit argument c'est un petit plus
que oui on y va c'est ce que j'arrive
premier ministre c'est médiatique ces
politiques sont d'accord bien sûr sauf
qu'elle a déjà un passif à tout à fait
il va falloir défendre justement se
défendre anne-claire rural ans oui c'est
défendre alors même si paradoxalement
c'est que 38 % des français n'ont aucune
idée finalement de qui elle est aussi
c'est ça qui est assez intéressant
essayons de 6% c'est aussi le choix d
emmanuel macron c'est à dire qu'on a
pris un profil qui n'est pas un profil
politique et un profil plus techno elle
est là pourtant depuis la nuit des temps
évidemment au gré des passations des
ministères mais mais d'une certaine
façon ça lui est favorable elle n'est
pas extrêmement médiatique à va le
devenir donc certes elle a un passif
calme afin qu'il va qu'elle va devoir
défendre mais le grand public figurez
vous que je pense qu'il attend très peu
en fait la prochaine recomposition de
ceux de ce gouvernement et il n'y a pas
une attente folles autour de ça
peut-être qu'ils attendent sur
législatives un peu plus d'être mais il
faudrait surtout s'intéresser aussi aux
français qui font sécession ou français
qui ne vont pas voter aux français qui
sont restés en marge aussi de toutes ces
élections et dessous de cette séquence
politique benjamin morel elisabeth
bornes c'est un atout pour elle
justement d'être qualifié de techno
expertes ça dépend cette bataille ont en
réalité alors pour cette bataille des
législatives pas forcément est là je
dirais deux handicaps majeurs la
première c'est qu'elle vient dans cette
majorité elle n'est pas un élément
nouveau et donc elle mobilise pas
d'autres électorats et ensuite parce
qu'on est fait là se profile techno qui
peut être extrêmement utile parce que le
rôle premier d'un premier ministre c'est
de faire marcher cette machine riquet
matignon cette machinerie de la connais
elle a fait est là était préfète de
région elle vient de l'équipement donc
pour les missions qui vont lui être
assignée elle est bien placée en
revanche pour mener une bataille
législative c'est beaucoup plus
discutable parce que en effet elle
mobilise pas différents électorats faut
comprendre que dans une élection vous
avez une forte abstention comme a priori
les législatives celui qui l'emportent
c'est pas celui qui a le plus large
électorat c'est celui qui arrive le
mieux à mobiliser sa base électorale et
pour ça il faut le motiver jean luc
mélenchon a bien réussi avec son affaire
de mois premier ministre ça marche
aujourd'hui dans l'électorat de gauche
en revanche pour l'électorat de la
majorité qui est moins menacée d'abord
parce que c'est un électorat
structurellement plus votants la
mobilisation aujourd'hui et pas
forcément acquise elisabeth bande va
avoir beaucoup à faire même si les
sondages les donnent encore largement
gagnant à d'après ce que j'ai vu et
parce que c'est un électorat neige alors
pas forcément premier tour se voulait le
vrai danger pour moi c'est pas tant que
vous n'ayez pas de majorité pour
emmanuel macron ou que la nuit par yves
avoir une majorité le vrai danger c'est
que la nuit soit premières au premier
tour et qu'ensuite la majorité passe à
la reine parce que pour des questions de
mécanique électorale en réalité si vous
êtes un parti centriste dans ce mode de
scrutin vous êtes profondément avantages
et si jamais ça arrive et ça créerait
une crise de légitimité qui pourrait
inaugurer à ces matches son quinquennat
toute la famille cobbe a tout à fait
déjà qu'on a une élection présidentielle
qui a été très escamoté par le fait qu
emmanuel macron on est entré en campagne
finalement que quatre semaines avant le
premier tour que dans de l'entre-deux
tours il a dit des choses assez
contradictoire à comprendre enfin je
veux dire on va faire la retraite à 65
ans mais 64 mais peut-être qu'on fera un
référendum on va faire avec les
partenaires sociaux ont fait la vie des
choses assez contracteur puis finalement
la chose la plus importante c'est la
question écologique enfin bon on sait
pas très bien ce qui a voulu dire il met
quatre semaines pour désigner son
premier ministre et son gouvernement est
donc finalement on est devant une
élection avec un contenu assez peu clair
et il est tout à fait possible et
probable même que la nuit paix ce soit
devant ensemble c'est à dire le
regroupement de la république en marché
de ses partenaires ce qui prouvait pas
qu'ils pourraient passer devant générale
annuelle
le nombre des d'exprimer ses vers le nom
mondiale deuxième tour bien sûr
favoriserait la république c'est le jeu
dès lors le vote politique c'est à dire
pour qui on vote quelle politique on
soutient emmanuel macron risque bien
d'être derrière la nuque ps jeanny fait
non mais moi je vous dis je suis
d'accord avec vous pour dire
qu'effectivement le programme notamment
des manuels macron pour toutes les
raisons que vous venez dire n'était pas
très très clairs et que s'il a remporté
la majorité c'est peut-être pas pour ce
qu'ils allaient faire bien qu'il y ait
eu quand même quelques indications sur
des réformes de droite faut-il le
souligner quand même la réforme des
retraites c'est ce qui est revenue à
fernand bon il a peut-être récolté
recueilli réunit des votes sur son
quinquennat sur le fait encore un effet
drapeau vous savez autour de la du chef
de guerre qui a continué à jouer mais je
voudrais juste pardon rebondir sur ce
que vous disiez l'un et l'autre je pense
que c'est quand même extrêmement
dangereux
sandy encore les
fragilités de fond encore une fois de la
présidence macron et c'est très
dangereux de dire qu'il y avoir une
crise de légitimité de par le tout à
raison que venait d'indiquer sur les
conditions d'élection et de candidature
de campagne et d'élections d'emmanuel
lac rond et celle qui se profile au
moment des législatives
même jean-luc mélenchon même jean luc
mélenchon n'a jamais parlé de
possibilités d'illégitimité pendant
cette présidentielle il y a qu une
personnalité paradoxalement qu'il l'ait
fait c'est le président l ère du sénat
qui après a fait un peu marche arrière
pareil pour les listes hâtif ce ne
serait pas un mauvais jeu si ce ne
serait pas la première fois en en raison
de du mois de scandale politique un
parti qui peut apparaître en tête n'a
finalement pas la majorité à la
présidence à la douzaine d'années blé on
va voir l'egypte comité un mot la notion
de légitimité se confond pas avec la
notion d'égalité la légitimité c'est la
narration légitime les raisons de
légitimité c'est l'acceptation par une
grande partie de la population de
l'ordre établi et du pouvoir hélas
aujourd'hui vous l'avez vu avec la crise
des jeux les jeunes employés partout en
occident nous sommes face à une crise de
légitimité dans l'ensemble des régimes
occidentaux
et en effet il ya un risque de
tremblement de terre oui d'accord mais
qui dépasse totalement germé au cas
français sur mais qu'il est 2e à doubler
conditions électorales que vous décrivez
piqué une crise et wierre enfants viol à
dire en voyant ces ondes ces deux noms
mais pas les intentions ne parle pas de
crise de légitimité dans une crypte à
ces jeux ça nourrit sanusi lamido de pas
mal de gens autour de notre démocratie
laiterie de légitimité et pour le coup
le mode de scrutin favorise aujourd'hui
en france où l'efficacité enfin ils
mèneront sur le mode de scrutin sont
lestés par mme marine le pen aussi donc
ça veut dire que deux des deux côtés en
fait ça peut être s'il ya deux pays qui
sont pas la première chaîne en europe
nous les britanniques c'est ça et ça
faisait presque partie des projets me
semble-t-il d'emmanuel macron de mettre
un peu de proportionnelle dans ses
oeuvres du manga déjà cinq ans il ya
déjà cinq ans en tout cas c'est la
deuxième journée ça tout le monde sera
d'accord pour le dire puisque c'est
factuel pour elisabeth bornes et
l'opposition on le voit même ici sont
ceux ce plateau et déjà vent debout
contre la première ministre alors on va
écouter mari le pen et on va écouter
également adrien à cape town ans
madame bornes cessé mes schémas khroubis
c'est le même c'est la même c'est le
même profil ce sont les mêmes idées
c'est la même vision froid de
administratif technocratique et en
réalité les mêmes réalisation brutale
donc je pense qu emmanuel macron l'a
choisi précisément pour mener cette
brutalité sociale qui lui tient à coeur
et qui va pouvoir s'exprimer très
rapidement à mon sens par
l'intermédiaire de cette réforme des
retraites le fait que ce soit elisabeth
bornes nommé premier ministre montre
bien que visiblement dans ce navire
l'équipage change de place c'est un jeu
de chaises musicales mais visiblement ya
pas de nouveaux passagers qui ont envie
d'y monter emmanuel macron a quand même
mis un certain temps avant de procéder à
cette nomination et au final c'est
qu'une ministre de l'air macron 1 qui se
retrouvent au premier plan de l'airmac
rondelle et parfois en fait c'est ça
tout cas c'est l'impression que ça donne
catherine tricolore à la fois la
continuité en même temps la casse
sociale voilà grosso modo pour résumer
ce que dit l'opposition c'est violent
certainement us mais c'est normal que je
veux dire la gironde et qu'on n'ait pas
simplement dans du commentaire politique
on est dans la bataille politique à une
élection législative donc tout le monde
essaie de faire valoir et je veux dire
on ne peut pas attendre autre chose des
opposants à emmanuel macron bon mais
ceci étant laisse que ce que vient de
souligner adrien catena c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est qu'en
effet emmanuel macron ne parvient pas à
élargir sa base politique et il n'a pas
totalement conforté son programme
puisqu'il l'a peut présenter et qu'il
n'a pas obtenu le deuxième tour son
élection est acquise aussi parce qu'elle
ce barrage contre marine le pen est au
premier tour il fait pas un résultat
enfin faramineux il fait 28 % des bois
c'est mieux qu'en 2017 mais ça ne fait
pas une forte légitimité pour introduire
alors je sais pas comment vous dis parce
que je sens que légitimité bauer c'est
ça ne fait pas cette scène un jour mais
ça ne lui donne pas le socle politique
pour faire les réformes particulièrement
celles sur la retraite qui a une
opposition
de la jeunesse et des salariés et donc
ça va être compliqué pour lui parce
qu'il n'a pas le poids politique pour le
faire il ne l'a pas élargie avec cette
campagne ni présidentiel ni probable
parce que sur les dossiers effectivement
il ya le pouvoir d'achat on a vu ce que
disait marine le pen lorsqu'elle parle
de casse sociale et puis effectivement
cette réforme des retraites la retraite
à 65 ans est ce que ça va être une
réforme effectivement qui pourra mettre
en oeuvre que elisabeth bornes pourra
mettre en oeuvre puisque ça va être un
de ces dossiers chauds si je puis dire
dans les mois qui viennent elle devra
s'y atteler j'imagine assez vite janyk
ah oui oui alors ça aurait pu être plus
vite parce que c'était prévu ddd l'été
voire dès l'automne la danse a été un
petit peu reporter vraisemblablement
pour laisser le temps notamment déjà de
mieux ficeler les dossiers ce qui
n'avait pas été le cas il ya trois ou
quatre ans et surtout surtout dit on de
la concertation donc madame board
effectivement elle et je pense qu'elle a
été notamment choisie pour mener cette
retraite 7,7 réforme parce qu'elle
connaît le dos et elle connaît
parfaitement le dossier elle sait ce que
c'est que c'est ce que c'est une femme à
poigne et c'est ce que c'est que se
concerter avec les syndicats les
syndicats le reconnaissent eux
reconnaissent que c'est effectivement
une femme à poigne mais qu'elle connaît
parfaitement ses dossiers elle sait ce
que c'est que parler avec des
organisations
syndicales et je pense aussi qu elle l a
mené des retraites extrêmement
décidément des réformes taylor
extrêmement difficile on en parlait tout
à l'heure la guerre à des agents de la
sncf et par le statut de la sncf la
réforme la réforme du chemin chômage
d'indemnisation chômage mais je pense
aussi que sa connaissance des dossiers
va lui permettre on peut l'espérer de
mettre en avant ce que n'a pas su faire
le gouvernement dans la séquence
précédente après on peut estimer que
c'est pas suffisant mais tout de même de
mettre en avant les points considéré
comme positif dans cette réforme qui ont
été totalement à plat ni éludée
lors de la première tentative je veux
parler oui ce n'est pas assez j'ai parlé
sur sur le financement non sur la
revalorisation
du minimal de d'accord qu'il ressent ces
mesures sur les ordres d'achat reçus
par le terreau des retraites du minimum
retraite et du et ainsi que de la
pénibilité et tout ce qui est la prise
en compte des emplois très compliqué ce
que n'a pas du tout su gérer monsieur
delevoye qui est l ancien négociateur
inquiète elle la négociation va être
difficile en tout cas puisque laurent
berger est prêt par exemple le
secrétaire général de la cfdt est prêt à
négocier mais il parle déjà d'un débat
sur les salaires nécessaire même s'il
est pas forcément du tout d'accord avec
jean luc mélenchon pour augmenter le
salaire à 1500 euros c'est toutes leurs
certitudes parce que quand on regarde un
homme politique quel qu'il soit et a
fortiori une une femme premier ministre
il ya trois choses qui rentrent en ligne
de compte ya un le style tout le monde
s'accorde pour dire qu elle est bosseuse
que les travailleuses qu'elle est assez
sévère avec ses équipes il est très
organisé on a aussi à côté du style
évidemment la méthode la méthode on sait
très bien qu'elle connaît très bien les
administrations centrales elle est
connue pour aussi batailler avec les
syndicats en permanence et assez aussi
dur dans ce dans ce jeu-là l'incertitude
aux rigidités parfois ses détracteurs
qui disent cela l'incertitude c'est
c'est le projet le projet politique
derrière parce que je rejoins ce qui a
été dit c'est 64 ans 65 ans enfin ça
reste assez flou c'est cette histoire
donc avant on faisait a demandé que ce
soit fixée et puis lundi l'heure si la
parole la concertiste sur la revanche
évidemment tout le monde à se
positionner sur le sujet c'est à dire
qu'en laissant maintenant le flou le
plus longtemps possible les jeux
politiques vont se faire pour pour
mettre le feu des projecteurs sur ce
sujet là et évidemment commencer à à
batailler sur 7 sur cette question là
pour essayer de montrer évidemment les
forme d'incohérence et ce qui m'inquiète
plus c'est que s'il n'y a pas eu de
conflit qualité au préalable durant la
campagne c'est à dire que si les
candidats ne se sont pas échangées elle
nous paraît changé en plateau justement
pour confronter des visions et se mettre
d'accord sur une forme de vision commune
et faire une forme de catharsis aussi
pour les français pour se mettre
d'accord sur une vision la
conflictualité risque d'arriver après
les élections et c'est là où c'est
compliqué c'est là où ça rejoint la
thématique de la la légitimité ou voilà
le fond ça comme on veut c'est la
défiance qui peut ressurgir a donc
apprécié il bat un moral de
effectivement cette réforme des
retraites pourrait entraîner une forme
de défiance ça veut dire pour des gens
dans la rue après les élections
peut-être à la rentrée en septembre
c'est ça que ça veut dire et un risque
ya un risque aujourd'hui vous avez une
très très forte déstructuration de
l'électorat et une partie de l'électorat
en fait est en rupture de ban et donc on
voit des phénomènes on peut revoir des
phénomènes type gilet jaune etc d'autant
que cette réforme elle est compliquée à
plusieurs enseignes la première enseigne
c'est que vous avez une réforme qui sait
de manière à tort ou à raison inscrit
tout comme étant structurellement
impopulaire la communication était très
très mauvaise et de trois ans et
aujourd'hui ça va être très très
difficile pour quel que soit le
titulaire enfin quel que soit le porteur
de la réforme de la sphère mieux passé
le deuxième élément c'est que vous avez
une réforme qui aujourd'hui beaucoup
moins audible quand vous faites une
réforme pour économiser 3 milliards
alors que vous avez lâché 10 milliards
par mois au moment du confinement bon
courage pour expliquer pourquoi cette
réforme est urgente et nécessaire quel
que soit encore une fois le bien fondé
de ses positions là le troisième élément
c'est que vous avez une majorité
parlementaire qui aujourd'hui est bien
si on part d'une part du prince du
principe que c'est une majorité ensemble
la reine qui aujourd'hui sans la menace
plutôt venir de la gauche et qui se
structurent allemand l'a vu d'ailleurs
dans le choix d'elisabeth bornes tourne
plutôt à gauche donc arriver à ne pas
destiné à gérer cette majorité en tous
cas au centre gauche et donc des
structures et cette majorité va être
l'un des dangers pour la prochaine
première ministre et elle va avoir
besoin justement de maintenir ces deux
pôles donc ça c'est du strict en guise
et du storytelling de dire qu'ils aient
baseband ça vient de la gauche vise à
melbourne ne vient pas de la gauche il
avait devant naples et depuis cinq ans
au gouvernement et elle fait toutes les
politiques les plus à droite les plus
libérales les rues de mahler avec des
personnalités de son bien même mais
quand bien même nom mais là elle a été
directrice de cabinet travaille dans
l'administration mais elle ce qu'elle a
fait depuis cinq ans venir d'eux ne fait
pas de vous une femme de dire que le tri
dans une homélie le jeu elle a fait les
réformes les plus hostiles au monde du
travail c'est elle qui les accueillent
la clarée la droite a beau tout à fait
il par ailleurs ce que je voudrais juste
dire c'est que la réforme des retraites
elle va avoir un peu de mal parce que la
réforme des retraites a été près des
halles a eu comme près des comores
c'est donc précédent pardon la réforme
sur l'assurance chômage ce qui veut dire
que les personnes qui ont par exemple 58
ans 59 61 62 ont des périodes de chômage
extrêmement courte on tombe très vite
dans le rsa ça veut dire qu'elle tombe
dans la misère et qu'elles auront encore
plus et des retraites encore plus
mauvaise donc ça veut dire qu'on a on
est devant une réforme des retraites qui
est déjà très dur mais en plus avec
cette réforme préalable sur la réforme
chômage mais c'est une catastrophe pour
les personnes qui ont plus de 55 ans
voilà à peu près et le bien-être et la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire c'est
que quand même ce qui est urgent c'est
pas la réforme des retraites dont le
régime fallait le corps nous dit qu'il
n'y a pas d'urgence ce qui est urgent
s'est occupé du réchauffement climatique
alors je m en valise et les deux simples
on ne t'a je n'avais pas on en parle on
va en parler bien sûr catherine frécaut
avance a juste parlé du pouvoir d'achat
parce que justement peut-être que pour
faire passer cette réforme des retraites
il ya d'abord ce paquet pouvoir d'achat
que l'exécutif gonfle en tout cas et
qu'il veut voter et faire voter en tout
cas avant l'été me semble-t-il avec un
texte qui va prolonger le bouclier
tarifaires sur les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité jusqu'à fin 2022 la
suppression de la redevance triplement
de la prime macron et puis également il
va acter le dégel du point d'indicé de
la fonction publique avec un certain
nombre d'autres réformes enfin d'autres
mesures on peut dire puisque des
réformes est ce que justement janyk
halimi ça risque de faire passer un peu
plus la pilule de la réforme des
retraites après est-ce que ça va être ça
d'abord la première chose est de toute
façon ça va l'urgence ça c'est clair
c'est de toute façon
l'urgence est là le pouvoir d'achat est
quand même beaucoup plus urgent est
d'actualité que la réforme des retraites
eu d'accord et tout ce qui vient d'être
dit et s'est inscrit pour le coup au
calendrier des dès la reprise des
travaux donc maintenant je ne pense pas
alors là vraiment d'abord je ne pense
pas que ce soit dans l'esprit du
gouvernement enfin quel qu'il soit
emmanuel macron dix ans et je ne pense
pas que
[Musique]
c'est ça pourrait avoir cet effet c'est
à dire
distribuer je crois que c'est évalué à
environ 20 milliards d'euros enfin sous
réserve d'inventaire les nouveaux au
coup de pouce j'allais dire au pouvoir
d'achat que vous venez de signaler je ne
pense pas du tout que une fois que les
français auront reçu est perçu ces
sommes la saa permettra de mieux faire
passer cette réforme qui est quand même
autrement plus lourde que celle des
retraites mais si je pouvais dire comme
juste une chose sur la réforme des
retraites juste je pense
qu'effectivement elle va créer une
opposition à mécontentement évident mais
alors mais contrairement encore une fois
à ce qui a été dit ou peut-être suggérer
je dis pas que vous le dit de façon
explicite veut dire ça fait partie c'est
pas du tout une sorte de contestation et
de défiance de des élus tel qu'il a été
à la présidence de la république dès
qu'ils le seront après les législatives
au contraire pour moi ça fait partie du
jeu démocratique tel qu'il est dans les
normes de des règles et de
fonctionnement démocratique qui sont
acceptées par tout le monde c'est à dire
qu'il y a un gouvernement qui l'amène
santé dans des belges a pris la relève
refusé d'en déballage et qu'il va
présenter qui doit passer par une
concertation et ses érections peut
estimer que ce n'est pas suffisant sur
la forme et sur le fond mais si liam et
contentement et je pense qu'il y en aura
ça devrait de toute façon être encadrés
par les syndicats qui auront négocié pas
assez peu mais qu'ils auront négocié ce
texte là et ça fait partie de la vie
normale d'une démocratie d'accord enfin
en tout cas il va y avoir du conflit la
vie oui parce que la vie normale d'une
démocratie mais si c'est un énième
gadget de concertation avec des
commissions chanteur de la contestation
voilà il fait partie de leur tout cas
cette réforme les regards étaient de la
feuille de route c'est ça de ce
gouvernement de fait intéressant en
revanche et de voir leurs pouvoirs du
parlement qui revient finalement
on tourne le contester
évidemment mélenchon en premier et
finalement ce parlement va redevenir un
lieu de discussion et de discussions
assez âpre si on en croit ce qui se
profile sera jamais l'homme n'y aura pas
mélenchon dans l'hémicycle benoît il
pensait que le parlement peut justement
à voir dans dans les institutions telles
qu'elles sont en france c'est moi j'ai
fait ma thèse sur le parlement alors
j'aimerais beaucoup vous dire que on va
vivre une rep and our parlementarisation
du régime allemand médiatique qu'il est
malgré tout je j'en doute un peu pour
plusieurs raisons en réalité d'abord
parce que
sur des charges et non mais surtout sur
des sujets aussi techniques que la
retraite en réalité vous avez une
administration une capacité d'action des
parlementaires qui est relativement
limités et donc à partir de là souvent
hills acte ce que leur donne l'exécutif
tout bêtement parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de construire une contre
expertise le deuxième élément c'est que
quand vous voyez les investitures
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas forcément
des parlementaires qui sont vraiment des
spécialistes des sujets osmo de l'ancien
magal et émissions oui mais les
commissions quand une fois elles sont
assez sous-dotées et vous avez des
parlementaires qui n'ont plus même si
elle doit avoir lieu dans l'analyse est
assez fragile elle va avoir lieu dans
les médias mais l'arithmétique
parlementaire malheureusement fabre ou
heureusement est implacable et ne
l'accablent donc elle va dans le sens
évidemment du gouvernement pour être
clair écologie donc on va en parler
parce qu'effectivement vous le disais
c'est le dossier prioritaire en tout cas
affiché comme tel par emmanuel macron
puis par elisabeth bornes en plus
aujourd'hui l'onu tire encore une
nouvelle fois la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le changement climatique qui reste le
plus grand défi de l'humanité a dit
l'organisation alors catherine tricot
europe ecologie les verts jugent que
elisabeth bornes partage avec d'autres
je cite un la responsabilité de ces cinq
ans de perdus pour le climat ayant
failli à faire voter des mesures pour la
convention citoyenne par exemple pour le
climat et ayant finalement échoué à
sortir des énergies fossiles c'est ça en
fait aujourd'hui qu'incarne elisabeth
bornes c'est oui elle a été ministre en
charge du dossier elle est ça n'a pas
duré longtemps mais elle a eu je dirais
en ayant eu des transports puis
l'écologie où je suis plus dans quel
sens ça s'est passé enfin il a eu les
deux transports en écologie c'est ça
voilà on est en eux transporte plus
d'écologie on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
se soit illustré au contraire c'est à
dire c'est quand même quand elle était
en charge du dossier que les nicotine
aux ide ont été de nouveau autorisé donc
je dis ce n'est pas la seule question
véritablement quand j'ai tout à l'heure
je parlais de des lignes qui sont
fermées à la suite de la de l'ouverture
à la concurrence de la sncf vers ça
c'est quand même un problème très
sérieux c'est un problème social mais
c'est un problème environnemental très
sérieux et pour l'instant il n'y a rien
on note que sait rien de ce qu'ils
entendent faire pour s'attaquer alors il
va voir au changement vous êtes vous
êtes vraiment très estivale dans votre
tenue fait 30 il fait plus de 30 degrés
à paris plein mais je garde c'est loin
possible la planification écologique en
tout cas le sait le mot lâché dont par
emmanuel macron et par elisabeth bornes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire elle elle
sera chargée donc la première miss de
cette planification écologique elle
devra être assistée manifestement par
deux ministres est-ce qu effectivement
ça peut accélérer les choses enfin en
tout cas l'intention est là ou pas faut
espérer en tout cas les nouvelles
méthodes les propos dans les propos
c'est été mis en avant entre les deux
tours 1 pour essayer quand même déçu de
la part d' emmanuel macron pour essayer
d'aspirer une partie de l'électorat de
gauche qui eux qui effectivement est
aimanté en tout cas qui a mis l'écologie
parmi ses priorités en n'hésitant pas à
reprendre là là les propos là le
vocabulaire pardon de la france
insoumise qui a été la première dès 2012
déjà de mémoire a parlé de planification
écologique donc gadget ou pas seul
l'avenir nous dira juste quand même
madame
bornes quand même à son actif et
isabelle borne basse juste à son équipe
c'est peu mais juste rappelons le le
plan vélo dans toute la france sauf de
réparation des vies mais elle a fermé
pas seulement est elle à fermer
fessenheim bon voilà non mais c'est
juste que je ne dis pas qu'elle est
l'incarnation de l'économie verte non
fessenheim décider si j'essaie d'en
oublier de la fermeture des petites
clean c'est peu juste pour rappeler sa
et pour montrer qu'effectivement c'est
peut-être enneigées voilà et juste pour
terminer ce que vous décrivez comme
effectivement une sorte d'écologie
transversale à tous le gouvernement je
pense est quelque chose de très
intelligent le problème c'est que ça
risque d'être pour le coup extrêmement
bureaucratique parce que pour essayer de
démêler ce que vous venez de dire est
qu'ils aient la présentation par le
président de sortes d'activités de pôle
écologique entre trois ministères il va
falloir l'expertisé de madame bornes qui
effectivement est réel de savoir parler
avec les différentes administrations
pour que l'écologie devienne concrètes
dans ce pays en revanche oui on pourrait
peut être suggérer à emmanuel macron que
s'il veut laisser une trace dans
l'histoire puisque c'est son dernier
mandat qu'ils s'emparent de ce sujet
finalement là on va la pression qu'il
l'a compris et qui éventuellement voilà
il ya des choses qu'il soit mis en place
pour mise en place pour pouvoir
marquer un peu ce qu'on quinquennat
voilà alors c'est sûr mais en dehors
justement de cette planification mise en
place et de ses ministres on ne sait pas
encore très bien comment faille et une
sorte de calendrier probablement 2030
2050 mais concrètement d'un point de vue
fiscal enfin bon ça reste encore flou
pour le moment oui mais c'est pas qu'une
histoire de fiscalité c'est surtout pas
une affaire de petits gestes du
quotidien c'est une affaire vraiment de
planification et je crois que là-dessus
emmanuel macron a compris que vous aviez
une nécessité en réalité d'intervention
de l'état c'est-à-dire sait ça relève un
peu de l'aménagement du territoire et de
la manière dont on construit de manière
générale et dont on coordonne les
politiques publiques les el hadjar
elisabetta ça veut souvent dire
fiscalité aussi oui mais pas forcément
envie
j ai accepté enfin on peut toujours
envisager des jeux en termes de
fiscalité lien mais il faut d'abord
envisagé une réintervention un
investissement de l'état dans les
différents territoires pour arriver à
construire un schéma économique et ça en
effet ça demande une coordination des
administrations je reviens sur ce qui a
été dit et là pour le coup le profil
d'elisabeth borne est plutôt un profil
intéressant elle est passée par
l'équipement elle est pas l a été préfet
de région elle sait comment fonctionnent
les administrations centrales mais
également des concentrés et autant on
peut douter de sa capacité politique à
tenir la majorité ou à mener la bataille
législative autant sur cette capacité à
coordonner les politiques publiques
c'est probablement la bonne personne au
bon endroit pour mettre en place des
sortes de paul non en fait vous avez vos
marques le coeur névralgique de
l'administration française il est pas à
l'elysée l'elysée cnpm le coeur
névralgique de l'administration
française c'est matignon c'est le
secrétariat général du gouvernement et
bercy et bercy a également et donc vous
avez besoin de quelqu'un qui maîtrise
ses fils là et ça c'est le premier
ministre et ce qui faisait savoir une
politique moi ce que je pense que là en
dehors du mot planification écologique
et d'une certaine manière et le plan
avait été donnée à beyrouth donc le mot
planification avait déjà avec la tête
effectivement dans la planification là
donc c'est un commissariat donc je
connais bien sûr mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que quelle est l'orientation
pour expliquer ce qu'elle devait donner
les orientations politiques 2 e on et
pour 8 mai mais moins ce qu'elle était
donnée les îles et les mets de défiler
dans mes attentes mais écoutez un tout
il ya eu quand même ah bah non je suis
désolé il ya comme une campagne
présidentielle il a dit moi je veux va
écouter il ya déjà
relancer le nucléaire on est pour en est
content on va pas se lancer dans ce
débat oui mais en face et non mais
attendez rapport est la moins chère
madame donc ça ne me dérange pas mais ça
suffit pas à faire une petite idée mais
écolo
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
élément structurant en matière de
politique énergétique et de politique
écologique et constables on est d'accord
mais ça a été clairement affichée oui
mais avec l'ouverture what else de je ne
sais plus combien de réacteurs je vous
prie de m'excuser des petits qui ont été
explicitement annoncé ce qui a été
explicitement annoncé et si c'est la
transition écologique vers des énergies
renouvelables et un plan au minimum de
mémoire qui était annoncé même avant le
premier tour dont il était un peu une
que j'allais dire une fin de quinquennat
qui était un plan de 30 hier d'euros
d'investissements donc c'est quand même
des grands axes qui demandait
concrétisait qui demande à être précisée
et qui demande à être mises en oeuvre
mais ne disons pas et ça a été le cas on
n'a pas besoin de beaucoup d'autres
candidats monsieur mélenchon a eu son
plan écologie monsieur jadot a eu son
plan écologie monsieur roussel y avait
du courage dans mes mails avait dû
compter cherche emmanuel macron qu'est
ce qui va bien au delà de relance et
madame en tout cas on y réalise lisez le
mais il ne dit que vous êtes opposés
mais on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'ya rien
eu celle-ci pas vrai après effectivement
ça va avoir un coût benjamin morel et
parfois bercy n'est pas forcément
justement ne va pas forcément dans le
même sens que les orientations
gouvernementales à ce que ja il risque
d'y avoir des frictions alors pour le
coup bercy va pas être le principal
problème mais il va y avoir un problème
financier c'est à dire que le problème
financier aujourd'hui il a trois aspects
qu'on voit ce discerner le premier
aspect c'est bon tu la montée des taux
d'intérêt le deuxième aspect c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une banque
centrale qui a fini qui visiblement veut
en finir avec le cas avec le
quantitative easing ce qui risque pour
le coup de fragiliser les opérations de
financement le troisième aspect c'est
que vous avez christian lindner le
ministre des finances allemand qui est
dit également qu'il allait falloir que
l'ensemble de l'europe se serre la
ceinture après la crise qu vide donc
lancé une grande opération sans parler
de la suède s'en font en effet risque
d'être assez problématique on va voir ce
que fera le gouvernement est ce que fera
emmanuel macron sapin pic probablement
un bras de fer avec lou avec l'actuel
gouvernement et si ça se borne à une
opération marketing avec un nom qui
claque un peu et quelques mesures qui
ont déjà été faites qu'on associe en
forme de package pour présenter quelque
chose comme d'un plan ça va pas passer
du tout évidemment après la nuque à
cette heure un bras de fer avec le
l'allemagne ça serait ça serait ça
catherine tricot gérard morel sur cette
question justement de l'écologie ah oui
au fait je pense que c'est un bras de
fer qui peut - je crois pas qu'il y aura
de bras de fer mais parce que je ne
crois pas dans la détermination de
démenait macron à faire une transition
écologique je pense qu'il va y avoir un
bras de fer sur des questions et
éventuellement financière avec l'europe
mais le problème là où je fasse ce qui
me semble vraiment problématique est ce
que contestent les écologistes la nuque
baisse et c'est à la proposition qui est
faite c'est pas de ces packs signé rien
au sens de il ya on va mettre des
éoliennes et on va mettre un plan
hydrogène et on va faire deux des
centrales nucléaires c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de vision de transformation
structurelle de notre économie de notre
façon de vivre de notre façon de
travailler de consommer et ses accès à
une transformation ce qu'il faut c'est
aller vers une vraie transformation de
notre société ce qui justifie de dire
que c'est le premier ministre qui s'en
occupe si c'est pour s'occuper
simplement de lancer huit réacteurs mais
je m'excuse n'y a pas besoin de mettre
le premier ministre alors là où je
voudrais devenir une rêverie vraiment
une transformation l'avouer c'est moi
réformage autre origine ne l'a pas
précisé le comprend mieux entre le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de mesure dans son
programme et le fait ou là je m'inscris
en faux et le fait où il n'y a pas de
vision véritablement révolutionnaire on
va dire au sens englobante au voisin que
doit porter l'écologie notamment pour
les écologistes ou pour la france
insoumise là je suis d'accord avec vous
mais pourquoi mais parce que emmanuel
macron notamment les socialistes en tout
cas beaucoup de socialistes également et
puis il y ait l'air également et le
rassemblement national il faut-il en
parler également ne met pas l'écologie
comme l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
révolution de la société ça c'est vrai
monsieur macron a bien dit que le
premier ministre avant qu'il ne la dame
devait devait être social écologique et
produits président bis dont
productiviste productif bon
enfin bon en tout cas on sait que la
vision de l'écologie de macron n'est pas
celle de monsieur mélenchon et de
monsieur jadot ça c'est je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous c'est
assumer en tant que tel par monsieur
macro on peut estimer que il a tort mais
on ne peut pas dire que l'écologie est
absente de sa vision du monde et de son
programme mais effectivement ces
contradictions peuvent apparaître
anne-claire ruelle par exemple sur la
sobriété ce qu'on appelle la sobriété
énergétique peut-être jour celle
qu'elles ont une vision j'ai envie de
dire c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron souvent je change de
visage en fait au fur et à mesure du
quinquennat entre 2017 et aujourd'hui on
sait pas qu'elle me emmanuel macron va
voir on sait pas quel cap il va à
impulser et c'est ça qui est dangereux
c'est que entre la start up née chaîne
de 2017 on a fait beaucoup de chemin
déjà aujourd'hui en 2022 mais on a
l'impression de quelqu'un qui est
protéiforme et qui échangent en effet à
ces plastiques et donc je rejoins ce qui
a été dit ces terres que au moins d'un
point de vue de la communication même si
ce n'est pas ça n'est que de la
communication mais ça joue beaucoup sur
la bataille de l'opinion qui se joue
dans les médias c'est quelle vision en
donne aux français et surtout qu'à
lequel on impulse ensuite en terme de
politique pour pouvoir rejoindre cette
vision et faire les choses benjamin
morel et en même temps sur cette
question climatique on voit l'onu on
voit qu'effectivement toutes les
organisations et tire la sonnette
d'alarmé donc il serait quand même très
étonnant qu effectivement il ne met pas
en place quelque chose et qui n'est pas
une exécution derrière ces quelques
annonces va devoir faire il va devoir
mettre en effet des choses en exécution
mais le problème si vous voulez c'est
pas une révolution effectivement il
faudra pouvoir une révolution
le climat puisse aller ans exactement la
question de la production et première
c'est à dire que vous pouvez voir des
opportunités économiques dans la
transition énergétique mais le premier
problème des français aujourd'hui désolé
de le dire c'est le pouvoir d'achat par
des charges y avoir roulé la hérarchie
des problématiques qui va être
extrêmement compliqué envisagé parce que
une partie de son électorat est très
attaché à la question écologique et donc
il ne peut pas la mettre sous le
boisseau d'autant qu'il a fait son
second tour alors je te vois vous re en
revanche la question du pouvoir d'achat
apparaît comme étant l'élément central
pour éviter une explosion sociale donc
il va falloir hiérarchisée il va falloir
concilier c'est pas tout à fait évident
aller en l'état je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit et
j'ajouterais même que aujourd'hui de
pouvoir d'achat et même la consommation
et politique aussi si on s'intéresse
justement à ces français qui s'éloigne
un peu de la politique c'est aussi un
moyen d'une certaine façon d'affirmer
des convictions politiques etc savent
aussi qu'ils jouent c'est à dire de
consommer pour une abrogation quand elle
peut passer le problème c'est quand elle
peut et comment est ce qu'on donne cette
possibilité là à tous moi ce que je
trouve étrange c'est que pour le pouvoir
d'achat nous dit je vous paierez plus
votre
apo / la télévision la leur a redonné
les devants ça vous fait rêver votre
redevance mais bon ça va coûter beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent finalement aux
contribuables d'une autre manière mais
peu importe ce que je veux dire c'est
que on pourrait aussi dire on va
vraiment vous aider à changer les
chaudières à changer vos véhicules à
isoler vos bâtiments ce n'est pas le cas
ce que dira il n'y a pas de grandes
politiques qui s'annonce sur ce terrain
là c'est sur le territoire thermique je
pense sa tribu abel ça va quand même
dans le sang non mais j'en mets plan
c'est insuffisant alors mal ou très mal
mal mal mal mise en oeuvre oui ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que c'est très très
loin d'avoir été mises en oeuvre et oui
alors à la hauteur de ce qu'avaient t
elle nous a fait on est à moins de 200
milles quand on en a usé 500 litres
c'est vrai donc la vraie organisation
existe non mais la préoccupation moi je
veux bien que il voulait que la planète
est soit grippe de gaines et que son
mandat serait écologique ou ne serait
pas ça peut ne pas tout à fait nous
suffire il faut que maintenant ils
allemand monsieur salon monsieur
mélenchon que vous semblez très bien
connaître voudra mettre aussi en oeuvre
sa peau parce que vous citez beaucoup la
du ps voilà c'est pour ça mais vous avez
totalement droit mais voilà et la
planification écologique est au centre
de la vision de la france à son vice
quand il voudra a entamé un bras de fer
avec le rock sans vouloir le quitter je
sais ce que l'europe s'aligne sur les
positions de la france et dans ce cas là
on va ça aussi c'est très compliqué
entre les propos et la mise en oeuvre il
ya souvent une grande différence juste
quand même un point pour revenir sur les
injonctions contradictoires que doit
faire peur preuves dont doivent faire
n'importe quel gouvernement entre le
pouvoir d'achat et l'écologie souvenons
nous de l'augmentation de la taxe
carbone qui a été les temps ce
l'étincelle à la crise et des gilet
jaune donc on a mis le doigt dessus avec
ce que je pense quand j'obtiendrai
lexique dès que ça entraîne c'est à dire
que pour le coup et on voit aujourd'hui
dans les mesures l'idée qu'il va falloir
concilier les deux et quelque chose qui
est bien et était qui et les leçons de
la crise et gilet jaune on peut s'en
féliciter ont été tirés justement
justement revenez sur un petit peu ce
qu'elle sera le point de friction avec
l'allemagne puisque vous alliez où vous
l'avez mentionné entre la france et
l'allemagne sur cette question assez les
ressources financières c'est à dire que
vous avez une allemagne qui aujourd'hui
entre guillemets s'autofinance c'est à
dire que les déficits sont faibles et
que vous avez une volonté du
gouvernement allemand de retrouver une
discipline budgétaire au niveau le
problème c'est que la france si jamais
elle veut engager une transition
écologique va avoir besoin d'avoir
recours à l'emprunt et pas de réserves
et donc ce faisant entre les injonctions
de christiane mineurs d'un côté et les
perspectives de planification écologique
des manuels macron il ya un hiatus on
peut aussi dire et de l'allemagne que
l'allemagne doit elle même car sa
transition parce que quand même
aujourd'hui la fiche d'ailleurs comme un
de ces héros musclé ses administrations
qui sont anémiques chute et qu'on n'ait
pas les mêmes priorités quand mes
l'admets mais l'allemagne est hébergée à
un bilan catastrophique sur le plan
écologique je veux dire elf elles
fonctionnent au charbon donc il y avait
bien falloir que l'allemagne elle-même
investissent pour arrêter ça elle est
dépendante au pétrole russe et au
charbon donc ça va pas du tout faux que
l'allemagne investissent massivement et
donc moi ce que je pense c'est qu
emmanuel macron devrait aller voir la
main aux en écoute faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose là on peut pas avoir
l'allemagne qui polluent et nouvelle
madame d'allemagne a déjà fait puisque
depuis la crise en ukraine dont environ
un an - donnant elle a déjà réduit de
moitié sa dépendance au gaz russe grâce
à des économies donc une sobriété et
grâce à un développement de des
importations de diversification des
importations de l'ue n'y a pas que pas
que elle me regarde le mot de la fin
c'est vrai que sera la politique
européenne en tout cas on est on a vu
que dans la feuille de route qu emmanuel
macron a écrit à madame bornes et ben il
y avait cette question de l'europe donc
on sait que ça va être aussi un des
dossiers importants oui c'est un dossier
important et c'est aussi un dossier sur
lesquels une finalement il est un petit
peu en terrain pas conquis puisque
évidemment il ya des jeux européens qui
sont complexes mais c'est son pouvoir
régalien aussi et donc c'est
traditionnellement le président a
toujours aussi beaucoup d'aura à
l'international et ils jouent souvent
l'international contre l'intérieur aussi
et c'est ça qui risque d'être un petit
peu ambivalent pour lui c'est que on lui
reconnaît des qualités à l'international
qu'on ne reconnaît pas forcément dans la
gestion de du pays en interne quoi si
vous vous dis merci en tout cas à tous
les 80 étaient avec nous benjamin morel
politologue maître de conférences en
droit public à paris de anne claire well
fondatrice de cole paul catherine tricot
directrice de la revue regards et janick
halimi rédactrice en chef adjointe du
service politique au parisien
merci à vous tous nous avons subi est
resté avec nous sur france 24